hello everyone my name is arya rostro
i'm a senior principal with alexa speech
org
i'm going to be talking uh and walk us
through some of their research
activities
that we are doing under a alexa isr org
so like she's already covered when a
user
talks with a device we try to detect a
record on device
and then we start streaming the audio to
cloud and in cloud we do
a bunch of classification tasks using
the audio
namely we try to do a speech recognition
we have to also
infer when the user is finishing the the
query
besides that we do a speaker recognition
whisper classification
and language identification that are all
form of
using using the audio that is a stream
to cloud
for asr specifically it is paramount for
us
to build a system that is robust to
different
uh acoustic scenarios and acoustic
context
different devices and it's also a
capable of covering
different dialogues and accents
to achieve this we build we latch on to
a large
data schema both in form of supervised
data and also unsupervised and
semi-supra was training
namely we build uh we use a pool of
labeled data across different locales
of variants of english for example enus
engb and ian and australian
we use the same pooling of the data when
dealing with our unlabeled and
unsupervised data
we mix uh of about
more than one million hours of
unsupervised data into our supervised
pool of supervised data and we we
pre-trained the models
using uh this uh pool data and then
fine-tuned the models
uh to to be locale specific we also have
to be
besides you know cross-lingual transfer
learning we have to also be cognizant
about
robustness to different noise and room
responses
our our story there is to use data
augmentations and our
techniques to to use a noise and
reverberation simulation
to to augment our data
um so conventionally asr systems
you know comprise of acoustic model and
a language model
so in in the previous slides we we
covered what is our what is our recipe
what is our research
in in building an acoustic model which
is robust to
different dialogues and different
acoustic scenarios we also at the same
time have to be able to
build a system that has a very strong
and robust language model one that is
capable of understanding
uh you know users queries
in in different contexts and scenarios
basically uh the the the solution to
this problem for us
is we we essentially latch on to a
a neural language model technology using
larger scale
neural language models that are utilized
in a second in in a two-part
two-pass-through scoring system
namely we process audio using the first
pass
large engram language models then the
output of the first pass
is re-escort in the form of lattice or
n-best
using a stronger neural language model
besides we make sure that this restoring
the re-scoring
neural language models are again trained
on a huge
amount of semi-supervised and
unsupervised data
basically we use roughly about one
billion uh semi-superwas data from our
production
machine transcript data to pretend our
neural language models
and then we further fine tune those on
on on
on the on the label data and then that's
how we build
a strong language uh neural language
model
um but we also want to make sure that
our language models
are domain ever so if you look at a
typical
uh you know usage for for for alexa and
voice assistance
different users have different type of
usage users can be
contracting devices to to carry like
shopping like uh queries
uh asking about like uh navigation
queries
or playing music or or many many more
domains
so it's very challenging to build a
language model which is
has a coverage over all these domains
yet very accurate in representing
all single domains so what we have come
up with
is that uh build a notion of domain ever
neural language models in in our second
past year scores
basically using an output of the first
pass and looking into the invest and
lattices
we infer what the underlying domain
should be
and using that information we dispatch
our neural second pass language model
scoring
to it to a to a relevant language model
as this can be seen here in the in this
graph
using this technique we we can we can
build
way more precise language models that
ultimately result
in insignificant water rate improvements
for specific domains
uh and more so on the slot level
um the other aspect of context is
to imp to to ingest context in the form
of
multi-turn interactions so
conventionally multi-term interactions
are are are
processed as a stand-alone interactions
but intuitively one can argue that
there is a huge amount of information
and persistency
in in in context when a customer
starts a multi-turn interaction with
their voice assistance
devices so for example here an example
query is
alexa call jeff and you probably
a customer has both jeff business and
jeff wilkin in their contact list
so alexa will start a multi-turn
interaction in the form of elicitation
to to understand user
means jeff bezos or jeff wilkie so the
tts response will be do you want to call
jeff bezos or jeff wilkie
and now at this point it's apparent that
we already know that we are just giving
the customer two options so
it is it is a really good idea to buy us
the language model for processing the
next coming
query from the user to make sure that we
are very robust
in recognizing you know jeff bezos and
jeff filke because we already have that
information
so basically using this observation we
have built techniques to use
multi-turn lstm neural language models
that are capable of
preserving the states and carry carrying
the context
across the turns and we have shown that
we get drastic improvements
when when when zooming into the
performance
asr on those sub-subsequent trends
as many of you know ever uh
the this is the new era of all neural
speech recognition and many
many many many many people in the
research community
and and uh uh are
are moving to uh showing gains and
popularity in using all neural speech
recognition
basically all known speech recognitions
are in the form of end-to-end models
you have a single model that is capable
of translating audio directly
to words without the split and breakdown
that we have in a conventional system
between
lexicon language model and acoustic
models the benefit of such system is
that
you you can train all the parameters of
the system
jointly and in one shot using data
and due to this joint training and the
fact that the whole
network is serialized and represented as
in one network
you have this this lends itself to to a
strong candidate for
low footprint settings because you can
apply
uniform compression and sparsification
techniques
to to basically shrink down the
footprint of the
the system and make it available to to
low footprint and constrain
scenarios so basically in september
uh using techniques from all neural
speech recognition
we have announced uh new echo
uh devices that uh include our custom
uh you know hardware accelerator uh
called
az1 neural edge processor and
using that uh hardware accelerator and
the ground up
uh you know all neural speech
recognition that we have recently built
we are able to to push and move
the full asr pipeline onto on on
on device and uh and process the audio
locally
and then just change the interface from
device to to cloud to be in the form of
the text
we still get the text to cloud but we
accelerate the audio processing
on device and then we do the the rest of
the execution
alexa pipeline execution in cloud
so when you deal with on device and
constrain uh you know
a resource constraint scenarios and
devices you have to be cognizant about
how you represent and you quantize your
models
you you i mean in most scenarios when
dealing on
uh with when you're going on device you
really cannot be
uh 32-bit representation you have to
come up with low bit representation
so basically uh in a paper that we we
present uh this year in
interest speed we have also come up with
a new techniques
for quantum applying quantized aware
training of our end-to-end
uh asr systems and
and basically the idea there is that as
opposed to
conventional quantization mechanism that
are only
really quantized ever at the forward
pass and they're not quantized ever at
the backward pass
when you're you're training the system
we have switched
and come up with a new new framework
where in we use
we imply quantize that we're trying in
the form of a
smooth regularization to come out to put
a prior on over the weights and make the
weights to be
you know way more
quantized friendly and we have shown
that this technique actually
worked very well in conjunction or for
an end-to-end speech recognition you
almost lose nothing
going to all the way down to six bit
representation
all right the the natural question after
each one and all neural asr is that why
to stop at asr
can we actually you know combine
the techniques and learn use the
techniques that are applied in an all
neural
speech recognition and essentially build
an all neural spoken language
understanding
uh you know uh models
conventionally uh when
when building in a spoken language
understanding the system comprised of
two separate and disjoined components
in the first in the first step you try
to translate audio using asr
into words to sequence of words and then
then comes in
downstream and the next step which is uh
which grabs a
sequence of words from the output of asr
and tries to
apply natural language understanding
techniques to to understand the intent
domain
and and the the slots that are that are
encoded in in in
in this spoken query uh there are
problems
with with this i mean there are benefits
to to
to doing the slu this way you have the
decoupling
different teams can can work on you know
optimizing different portions of the
system
but the problem the drawbacks are that
like what we said in the end to an asr
uh you you are optimizing the full
stack in a very using separate loss
and objective functions in a very
disjoint way this might not be the most
optimal
scenario in terms of accuracy basically
usually
the errors from asr do cascade down to
nlu
and nlu has not seen those errors and
confusion so
that that can can can can result in
errors cascading down to the whole
execution pipeline
the other part of it is that really when
you think about it
we are not optimizing system to to be
accurate for the parts that matter in an
unspoken query
so in a spoken query can compromise
comprise of
you know many you know functional
function words or
or words that don't really matter like
hesitation
in in changing the meaning of the
semantic meaning of a query
yet we are optimizing the asr to get
everything right and then you destroy it
to get everything right but by putting
things together
and combining them into one one uh you
know
end-to-end speech to semantic system we
are able to to get the benefit
all of the benefits i mean namely we are
able
through to overhauling the interface
between asr and lu to become all neural
to be able to number one to apply a
joint optimization for an overall goal
of
building a highly optimized slu system
number two because of that because
asr now the system is jointly trained uh
nlu is capable to handle and is learned
and trained to handle the
the ambiguity and asr errors that are
cascaded to nlu
number three is that by by having access
to nlu output
and loss when building the system
we are able to also back propagate the
error signal from the semantic level to
the asr
meaning we are able to improve the asr
at the parts that that that matters
we actually show in the paper that we
present in this speech that this results
both
improvements in the overall slu
performance but also
on the intrinsic you know in performance
of asr
meaning rate and then once
like what we talked about into an asr
once you did that
this system lends itself to to to
to to better compression and throughput
meaning accuracy per per footprint
and making it more even more attractive
to to deploy such system for for
constrained uh
you know a resource environment such as
undevised
and why do we want to do that because
beyond accelerating audio processing
we want to be able to also do the nlu
and
and and and perhaps speechless and
domain execution
locally to be able to even get further
further latency improvements
so these are some of the some of the
research uh topics that we are
uh we are dealing with in the alexa asr
org
and some of the techniques that we are
presenting in interest page
so with that i'm going to conclude and
hand mike to to my colleague andrew
thank you